ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูป๊าสวัสดีค่ะครูเรียมสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
กลับมาช่องคอมเพลนสิเบอร์ไทยนะคะในวีดีโอ
บีกินเนอร์ 4 น้องให้แบแล้ว
[เพลง]
วันนี้ที่เราคุยกันอยู่เป็นวันอะไรคะหมู
ป่าวันนี้เป็นวันพุธค่ะครู RE แฮมเป็นวัน
พุธ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 17 วันที่ 17 เดือน
เดือนสิงหาคมสิงหาคม
ปีพศอะไรคะปีพตต
แล้วปีคศอะไรคะปีคศ 2  022 ค่ะ
ตอนนี้กี่โมงแล้วคะครูแต่ตอนนี้
11:00 น
24 นาทียี่สิบสี่นาที
เย้ไอออกก็มาทดสอบความอดทนของครูฟ้าเป๊าะ
อันนี้เป็นไงแม่อีพิโสด 2 นะคะทำไมเรื่อง
เล่าของเกรียมไม่ใช่ความรุนคว้านะกูจะไม่
มีหา
ไม่หิวไม่ไหว
ฝันว่าถือว่ามีความอดทนอยู่นะหรอว่าอดทน
ที่ไม่กินข้าวใช่ไหมใช่แล้วก็เหมือน
เรื่องที่เราจะมาคุยกันต่อนี่แหละ
จาก Ep ที่แล้วนะคะถ้าใครยังไม่ได้ดู
วิดีโอก่อรกลับไปดูวีดีโอที่แล้วก่อนเนาะ
แล้วก็เดี๋ยวนี้เป็น
พาส 2 ดา EP2 มีของเคมีคือเป็นยังไงต่อคะ
คุณเรียมวังที่ธก็บอกว่าพระราชาเนี่ยทด
สอบความปวดทนของพระเตมีย์เยอะมากทดสอบ
หลายอย่างมากใช่ตั้งแต่เด็กๆแล้วใช่ไหม
ที่เราบอกว่าหิวหิวนมอยากกินนมก็ไม่ให้
กินเพราะอยากให้ร้องไห้มึงไม่โอเคเลยแล้ว
ก็เอาผลไม้เอาอาหารมาวางไว้
ให้อยากกินนะเวลาคนเราอยากกินแล้วก็อยาก
หยิบมาเอาเข้าปากแล้วก็กินใช่ไหมใช่ฮะ
เวลาของเราหยิบไม่มีก็กำลังแบบแป้งเป็น
ง่อยอยู่
แกล้งเป็นง่อย
ไม่เรียบตัวอยู่นิ่งๆแรงหูหนวก
แรงไม่ได้ยินหูหนวกๆถ้าแต่มีก็อดทนใช่
แกล้งเป็นใบ้เป็นใบ้ด้วยอ่ะ
ถ้าไม่ได้ใช้แล้วเรามันมีมากกว่านั้นค่ะ
ฟ้าพระราชาก็แบบอยากคิดว่าพัชรีมีเนี่ย
ไม่ได้เป็นง่อยไม่ได้หูหนวกไม่ได้เป็นใบ้
ง้อเลยเอาไฟมา
ไป
เฮ้ย
ไฟที่หล่อๆนะ
Fi มาทำอะไรคะคุณเรียมไฟมาแบบใกล้พระเต
มีย์
ท่าพระแต่มีร้อนก็จะแบบวิ่งหนีคืออะไรอ่ะ
ช้าก็จะได้รู้อ่ะพระนางมีไม่ได้เป็นง่อย
แล้วพระเตมีย์ทำยังไงอ่ะข้าได้มีก็อดทน
ไม่วิ่งหนี
ไม่ร้องไม่พูดหนู
อุ่นทนมากยังเด็กอยู่เลยนะคะหือเด็กอยู่
เลยนะแล้วจะเอาไฟมาใกล้ๆพระเตมีย์ก็ยังอด
ทนได้
พระราชาก็เลยเอาช้างมาเอาช้างว่าทำอะไร
เรียนช้าง
ช้างกับเรียนวาดรูปได้ไหมได้คุยว่าลูกได้
[เพลง]
ช้างมา
ช้างน่าจะตัวใหญ่มาก
ใช่นะกลัวแล้วช้างว่าทำอะไรคะคุณเรียมเอา
ช้างมาแล้วก็แบบช้างเนี่ยจะมาเหยียบภะเตน
อี
โง่ท่าช้างเหยียบเราเราก็ตายตายช้างตัว
ใหญ่ฉันท่าช้างมาถ้ามีจะได้วิ่งหนีใช่ไหม
ใช่
เพราะจะมีจะได้วิ่งหนีแต่พอที่ช้างเนี่ย
เข้ามาใกล้ๆใกล้ๆพระ thanee คะได้มีก็ไม่
ขยับตัว
นิ่งว่าถ้านิ่งมากไม่พูดไม่ร้อง
ไม่ขยับตัวพี่หนูเลยอ่ะก็เลยมีคนมาแบบ
อุ้มพระเตมีย์ออกไปเพราะว่ากลัวช้าง
เหยียบใช่เราพระราชารักลูกไม่ใช่หรอไม่
กลัวลูกมายหรอกลัวลุ้นตายต่อก็อยากรู้คน
พระราชทานคิดว่าพระเตมีย์ไม่ได้เป็นง่อย
หือ
แบบนี้พระราชาชื่อหรือยังคะราชาก็แบบยัง
ยังไม่เชื่อยังไม่ช่วยหรออย่างกระเทียมก็
อยากให้พระราชาเชื่อนะ
ผู้ใช้ยังไม่เชื่ออีกแล้วทำยังไงอีกคะคุณ
เรียมพระราชาก็เอางูมา
เอางู
อนาคอนด้าหรือเปล่าไม่รู้นะ
เอาหน้าไปทำคันรอบตัว R
จะ
เอาเงินอสสรอบตัวของพรรคที่มีใช่ไหมเพื่อ
อะไรอ่ะเพื่อจะให้พระเตมีย์กลัว
พรรคที่มีไม่กลัวเหรอคะอ่าได้มีกลัวแต่
ว่าก็อดทน
[เพลง]
เป็นเหลี่ยมนะเดี๋ยวไปตั้งแต่หิวข้าวแล้ว
ไม่ไหวเหรอแต่พาดๆมีก็อดทนนะหัวโหเจอ
หนูนะเรียนเห็นแล้วก็
[เพลง]
เดินกลัวคือเวลาหรอกหรือว่าสะพัดนี้ก็อด
ทนมาก
อะราชาก็เลยคิดอีกด้วยค่ะนี่ในนั้นทำยัง
ไงดี
ทำยังไงจนหา The  mid โตคือนี่อายุเท่า
ไหร่หรอคะผู้รินประมาณ 16 ปี
อายุ 16 แล้วโตแล้วเนาะปกแล้วเต็มตัวแล้ว
ก็เลยคิดว่าผู้ชายที่โตขึ้นมาแล้วต้องชอบ
ผู้หญิงสวยๆ
เฮ้อใช่ก็เลยหาผู้หญิงสวยๆมาแล้วก็แบบ
จำให้ผู้หญิงมานะเราบอกว่ามาเหมือนมา
เจอมามันจับนั่นแหละมาจับแล้วก็เขากับพระ
ราชาคิดว่าผู้ชายต้องชอบผู้หญิงหนุนสวยๆ
ผู้หญิงเซ็กซี่อะไรเงี้ย
แล้วเป็นอย่างไม่ได้ค่าแต่มีคนได้ไหมอดทน
ได้ไหมค่ะได้มีก็อดทน
สบายมากค่ะเพราะว่าพัชจะมีเดี๋ยวเจอช้าง
เจอไฟเจิงงูก็ยังทนได้เลยผู้หญิงคนได้
อยู่แล้วเอ้าพระราชอาสน์จะคิดว่าแบบแต่
ผู้หญิงสวยคะแต่มีต้องเปลี่ยนใจต้องแบบ
ชอบผู้หญิงสวยต้องแบบขยับดีกว่าต้องจับ
ผู้หญิงอะไรแบบเนี้ยแต่ไม่เลย
ใช่ไหมไม่
ไม่เลย
ขอทนหน้าที่นี้ก็เลยมีพราหมณ์
รำบ้างอา
[เพลง]
ค่ะวันนี้เป็นยังไงๆมีครามนี่แหละมาบอก
พระราชามาบอกว่าพระเตมีย์เนี่ยไม่ดีถ้า
อยู่ที่บ้านอยู่ที่วังของพระราชาน่ะ
ไม่ดีต้องเอาออกไปข้างนอก
แล้วจะให้พระเตมีย์ไปอยู่ที่ไหนคะครู
เรียมถามก็เลยบอกว่าต้องเอาพระ Rainy ไป
ฝังในป่าช้าเอาไปฝั่งนักเรียนฝั่งเนี่ย
ถ้าเกิดคนตาย
เราต้องฝันใช่มั้ยใช่เราต้องฝังอันนี้
เป็นพื้นดินใช่ไหม
เราก็ต้องแบบ
ขุดหลุม
ก็จะมีพวกใช่ไหมค่ะเริ่มจะวาดเหมือน
เออก็ไปตักดินขึ้นมาหมุนขึ้นมาอุดขดแล้ว
ก็อันคนที่ตาคะแล้วก็จะเอาใส่ในหลวง
เราก็จะเอาดินลงมากลบ
เป็นการฝังนะฝัง
ถามก็เลยบอกว่าต้องเอาพระเตมีย์ไปฝังแต่
พระเตมีย์ยังไม่ตายไม่ใช่หรอ
ทำอย่างนั้นได้ยังไงยังไม่ตายเขาบอกว่า
ถ้าเกิดฟางเนี่ยแล้วบ้านพระราชาในเขาต้อง
ดูแลคนหลายๆคนใช่ไหมถามบอกว่าคนหลายๆคน
ที่อยู่ในเมืองของพระราชาน่าจะดีขึ้นแล้ว
พระราชาชื่อไหมคะอะราชาเชื่อแต่พระราชทาน
เสียใจนะเมื่อเช้าเนี่ยใจเหรอว่าเราก็รัก
ประชารุ่นรักชาวบ้านเหมือนกันรักรูปคือก็
เข้าใจว่าเป็นพระราชาเนาะก็อาจจะต้องทำ
เพื่อคนอื่นๆนะเขาต้องดูแลคน
100  200  300 คนเนี้ยบางทีก็ต้องทำชาย
ก็เลยโอเคอ้าเอาพระเตมีย์ไปฝังใช่คน
เลี้ยงได้ให้เอา Part  A นี้ไปฟัง
พระเลิกนับได้มีก็ต้องตายอ้ะ
แล้วก่อนที่จะเอา Part  A มีใบเนี่ยพระ
มเหสีในพระราชินีอะไรก็ร้องไห้ร้องไห้
เสียใจมาก
ลูกอ่ะอะไรที่นี่ก็เลยพูดกับพระตีมีบอก
ว่า
แม่รู้ว่าพระเตมีย์ไม่ได้เป็นง่อยไม่ง่วง
ไม่
แล้วรอมพูดเถอะพูดออกมา
ว่าร้องไห้เสียใจมากคือถ้าลูกพูดออกมา
โอ๊ยลูกจะได้ไม่ต้องโดนฝังใช่
ค้าแต่มีเห็นแม่ตัวเองร้องไห้
เป็นหยังสึกอ่ะห้องหัวเสียใจ
ทำไม่ร้องไห้นะคะเสียใจไม่เป็นไรแล้วก็จะ
มีทำยังไงคนเลี้ยงค่าตั้งมีก็คิดว่าต้อง
อดทน
อดทนแม่จะร้องไห้ก็ต้องอดทนมือจะไม่พูด
เพราะตัวเองตั้งใจไว้แล้วว่าจะไม่เป็นพระ
ราชาค่ะแล้วเกิดอะไรขึ้นหลังจากนั้นหลัง
จากนั้นก็คือพระราชาให้คนเอาพระ thanee
ใส่ใส่รถม้า
ที่หานี่คือรถม้าเนี่ยก็จะมีม้าอยู่ 1
ตัวนี้หมาก็มีรถอยู่ข้างหลังไงดีมันจะ
เป็นแบบนึงนะแต่
รถติดผู้ชายคนนึงที่เป็นคนแบบนายม้า
ผู้ชายขับ
นั่นแหละที่เราเห็นนั่นแหละที่เป็นฉันจับ
เชือกนั่นแหละม้าก็ขับรถมาไปได้พระเตมีย์
ก็อยู่ข้างหลัง
แล้วนี่นอนไปจนถึงจนถึงป่าช้า
ป่าช้าก็คือที่ที่แบบเขาเอาคนตายไปฝังมัน
คนตายไปฝังในดินเยอะๆใจให้เป็นป่าน้อง
เรียนเป็นป่าป่าๆเป็นไปฉาย
แล้วถึงป่าช้า
คนขับรถม้าก็ลงมาแล้วก็
ขุดดิน
ร่วนขุดดินค่ะเสร็จแล้วค่าแต่มีก็รู้แล้ว
ว่าตัวเองออกมาจากวางแล้วค่ะเอาแต่มีก็ดี
ใจเฮ้อ
ดีใจอดทนมาตั้งนาน
แล้วเป็นยังไงอะได้มีก็เลยลุกขึ้นมาขยับ
ตัวมาก
พ่อออกจากวางแล้วไม่ต้องเป็นง่อยไม่ต้อง
หูหนวกไม่ต้องเป็นใบ้แล้วใช่มาแต่มีไม่
ได้ขยับตัวมานานก็เลยคิดตัวเองเนี่ยยังมี
พลังเยอะอยู่หรือเปล่า
ก็เลยลองโจ๊กรถม้า
แล้วเป็นไงโอเคแข็งแรงมากให้ยกรถมาได้
แล้วขึ้นรถมาเห็นไหมคนขับรถมาไม่เห็นคน
ขับรถมากำลังขุดดิน
ขับรถมากำลังขุดดินอยู่ก้มหน้าขุดดินอะ
ได้มีกระจกรถมาเพื่อ
มาเพื่อแบบดูว่า
มีพลังเยอะอยู่แล้วหลังจากนั้นเกิดอะไร
ขึ้นคะหลังจากนั้นก็เดินมาหาคนขับรถม้า
หนึ่งก็มาบอกว่า
จะฝังจะฝังจริงๆหรอ
ฝั่งฉันจะฝั่งฉันจริงๆใช่ไหมให้รักมาฉัน
จริงๆใช่ไหม
มันไม่ดีนะเราเดี๋ยวกับฆ่าคนไม่ดีอือแล้ว
เกิดอะไรขึ้น
เขาเต็มนี้ก็เลยบอกว่าถ้าเป็นคนดี
ถ้าเป็นคนดีไม่ฆ่าใครจะอยู่ที่ไหนก็จะมี
คนช่วยเยอะๆเป็นคนดีเป็นคนดีนะ
นี่
แล้วคนขับรถมากเลยคิดผู้ชายคนนี้เป็นใคร
มันเขารู้ว่าไม่รู้จักผู้ชายคนนี้เป็นใคร
และ
ก็เล่นเดินเดินไปดูที่รถม้าค่ะไม่เห็นพระ
เพณี
ก็ยอมหน้านี่ภะเตมีหรอ
อะไรมีทำไมเดินได้ล่ะได้คนขับรถมาก็เลยดี
ใจฮื้อแล้วจะเอากลับไปบอกพระราชาไหมให้จะ
เอาไปบอกพระราชาเราว่าพระเตมีย์ก็บอกเรา
ไม่อยากไม่อยากกลับไปเป็นพระราชาอยากบวช
อยากเป็นพระเช้า
เลยขอบวช
แล้วพอบวชมาแล้วก็เลยแบบมาสอนสอนธรรมะให้
คนขับรถมาด้วยนะเออมาก็เลยอยากบวชเงี้ย
เอ้อแล้วก็ขับรถมาก็เลยบวชกับพระเตมีย์
เป็นพระบวชให้คือผู้ชายเนาะก็จะไปเป็นพระ
นะคะให้คณะพุทธพระเตมีย์ก็เลยบอกว่าถ้า
อย่างนั้นก็ไปบอกพ่อกับแม่นะดูก่อน
ว่าจะบวชมาบวชใช่
อ่ะโอเคคนขับรถมาก็เลยไปหาพระราชาไปหาพระ
ราชินีบอกว่าคะแต่มีไม่ได้เป็นร้อย
ไม่ได้หูหนวกไม่ได้เหมือนว่าไอ้ถ้าคนก็ดี
ใจมากแล้ว
ทำไงต่อพ่อกับแม่ก็เลยมาหาพระ thanee
เราจะมาบอกว่าให้พาจะมีกลับไปที่บ้านจะ
เป็นพระราชา
แล้วพระจะมีกลับไปเป็นพระราชาไหมคะแต่มี
ก็เลยบอกว่าไม่อาจจะมีอยากจะบวชแบบนี้ไม่
อยากมีสมบัติอะไรนอนเนี้ยมีความสุขดี
แล้วก็เลยอยู่ด้วยกันก็ภายในนี้ก็สอนสอน
ธรรมะ
ธรรมะคืออะไรดีๆหรอพระเนี่ยผู้ต้องทำนะ
นี่คือจะพูดในเรื่องที่ดีแบบถ้าคนมันไม่
ดีนะพ่อทำแบบนี้ไม่ได้หรืออันนี้คือธรรมะ
แล้วก็พูดแล้วพ่อกับแม่โอเคไม๊ฟังไหมพ่อ
กับแม่ฟังฟังแล้วก็ไม่อยากได้สมบัติ
ไม่อยากมีเงินแหวนไม่อยากได้อยากอวด
พ่อกับแม่ก็เลยบวชอยู่กับพระเตมีย์ใช่ไหม
คะให้ขบวนกับคะแต่มีคนที่อยู่ในเมืองชาว
บ้านก็แบบว่าบวชกับพระ thanee
แบบอยู่กันเยอะมากเป็นพระกันหมดเลยนะคะ
เราทุกคนก็ไม่สนใจเลือกแหวนเรื่องสร้อย
ไม่สนใจเงินในอ๋อ
ก็คือกลายเป็นว่าพระเตมีย์เนี่ยก็เลยให้
ทุกคนมาบวช
ใช่ใครอยากบวชมาบวชเป็นพระกันแล้วก็ดี
แล้วเนี่ยแล้วพระราชาจมีคนอื่นๆได้ยินว่า
พระราชาเมืองนี้
ไม่เอาสมบัติไม่เอาเงินไม่เอาทองก็เลย
เดินเดินๆมาแล้วจะมาเอาสมบัติของเมืองนี้
ถ้า
ขโมยเลยแล้วเนี่ยไม่ต้องขโมยค่ะคือไม่มี
ใคร 4 เสียทีแล้วเราจะดีใครจะเอาก็เอาไป
เลยแล้วเป็นยังไงต่อคะพอมาถึงแล้วก็เลย
ส่งสัยสมบัติไม่มีคนสนใจ
แต่ว่าทุกคนไปหาพระเตมีย์ก็เล่นอยากรู้
อยากรู้ว่ามีอะไรทำไมทุกคนไม่เอาสมบัติ
เหรอเออก็จะไปหาแต่เงินไปหาพระเตมีย์ค่ะ
แล้วก็บวชกับพัดอยู่ดีๆก็คือพอไปถึงพระเต
มีย์ก็สอนธรรมะพูดเกี่ยวกับเรื่องธรรมะทำ
ให้พระราชาเมื่ออื่นๆที่จะมาเอามีบัตรฟรี
น่ะก็เข้าแต่มีพูดดีมากเลยชอบอยากบวชแล้ว
ไม่อยากมีสมบัติไม่อยากมีเงินไม่อยากมี
ทองไม่อยากมีอะไรเป็นพระกันหมดใช่มั้ยใช่
ใช่อะไรก็เรื่องของพระเตมีย์ก็มีมาแบบนี้
นะคะเอ่อเขาเขาจะสอนว่าน่ะต้องมีความอดทน
ถ้าเรามีความอดทนอะไรที่เราอยากได้เราก็
ทำได้ใช่ๆอดคนแล้วก็จะได้สิ่งที่เราอยาก
ได้
นั่นแหละฮะก็ก็ประมาณนี้เป็นเรื่องที่ดี
มากเลยค่ะโคเรียมดีมากเลยที่โคเรียมเอามา
เล่าให้เราฟังนะคะให้คุณมากค่ะก็ฟังนะ
แล้วก็อดทนดีแต่เรียงก็อดทนไม่ได้เท่าพระ
เตมีย์ใจไม่งั้นเราก็จะเป็นพระใช่ละอาจจะ
ต้องแบบๆแล้วร่วงแล้วอ่ะโอเคแต่วันนี้นะ
หมดเวลาอามาโคเรียมใช่ค่ะเย้ว่าไปกินข้าว
ดีกว่าค่ะเจอกันวีดีโอหน้านะใครไม่เรียน
ไงคะวันนี้ต้องลาไปก่อนแล้วค่ะไม่ค่ะช่อง
ที่ดีก็กดไลค์นะคะโอเคค่ะบทสุดท้ายค่ะได้
ค่ะถ้างั้นก็สวัสดีค่ะวันนี้ค่ะอ่ะ